make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with the origin of isaiah bradley part
two right the truth red white and black
the story of the black captain america
okay so uh in the previous video we
basically ended with this idea that
isaiah bradley and these various other
african-americans had all been taken
by essentially the us government whisked
off to a camp that didn't really exist
in mississippi
and then basically subjected to a series
of terrible processes in order to
recreate captain america steve rogers
right because steve rogers was off
fighting in world war ii at that time
and they saw him as a success and they
suddenly wanted to create more what this
does at least this the second half this
conclusion is going to give us a lot of
information especially what happened to
isaiah but it's also going to fill in
what was going on behind the scenes in
terms of
the fact that it's a lot more complex
than we were initially told right so
one of the first things that happens
here and this is one of the things we
talked about in the last video
is that in order to ensure that nobody
would come looking for these soldiers
that the us government had created a
cover story right and basically said
these guys had all just been killed in
like bombings and different events and
so on and so forth now where a lot of
the other
individual families ended up more or
less accepting this
faith the wife of isaiah bradley did not
she did not accept this as an absolute
truth and at the very least wanted to
see her husband's body the results of
this is that she was kind of roadblocked
every single time she tried and every
time that she was turned down
she became more and more suspicious
right that if her husband really did die
then it's like okay then like i need to
find out what's going on and when she
finally saw the body
she realized something was off right and
so what ended up happening is when she
went to go visit the military she was
kind of like okay when i saw the body of
my husband it was the charred body of a
white man so like
what in the world is going on here right
like why is my husband's body replaced
with a white guy and so we're again
she's kind of railroaded and not really
given any any actual answers outside of
the fact that he was just kind of burned
beyond recognition
uh in the end it was just kind of you
know just that's the way it is and she
was kind of sent on her way now as she's
leaving she's met by
a black member of the military who
basically tells her that what ends up
happening a lot of times i don't know
how true this is
but what ends up happening a lot of
times is that when there's bombings that
take place with regards to
you know various soldiers that usually
they're blown to pieces and that what
the government does is try to assemble
at least some variation of them
in order to actually have a body in the
casket and so they'll have like a suit
on and things like that they'll make
them look as clean as they can
but like their legs might be
disconnected or something like that you
just won't know because there's
basically they're sitting in a casket
and there's pants covering their legs
and so it's one of the things where it's
just kind of like it's the nature of
this but what he does is kind of provide
this kind of
you know almost bottom level uh
indication
that like it's a cover-up right he
doesn't really say it in so many words
he doesn't really say no don't worry
like your husband
like he didn't die in a bombing the
government's lying to you he doesn't
really say that instead it's just kind
of like well i mean you know they kind
of put them together and
and so on but it's kind of pointing to
this idea that like the body in the
casket is not your husband but instead
of just kind of leading it and saying
like it's not your husband because the
government just did the best they could
with what they had instead it's
there's something a little more
nefarious going on but the reality of
this and what she kind of walks away
from is
she's never going to get isaiah back now
the reality of her husband
is that he alongside a few other members
of the of the group
are kind of fighting out in the german
black forest right and as they're going
through and facing off against these
germans and they take these guys out
based on the assignment they were given
by the military they end up finding out
that what they were
there to do was to essentially
inter-intercept a supply line
and inside one of these trucks is a
bunch of pharmaceuticals or a bunch of
uh
what look like medicines from hope
pharmaceuticals now there is a huge
thing behind this and it's not what they
think it is but from their perspective
they believe it's like bandages and
medicines and there's a huge mental toll
that comes with this because they feel
like they've been sent on a mission to
essentially
intercept supply lines to keep the
germans from being able to
tend to the tender they're injured now
the reality of this is that is exactly
what happened
right i mean and not not necessarily in
the story but like in world war
ii uh that's exactly what happened there
were multiple instances
where the us military would engage in
these supply line interceptions that
were designed to basically
keep germans and italians and members of
the access access powers from being able
to tend to their wounded right it was
the one of the most effective ways of
being able to keep them from
keeping their supply lines maintained by
keeping their soldiers happy and healthy
in some ways they turn it into a war of
attrition but one of the things that
kind of goes on is that this creates a
kind of mental toll for these guys right
especially for maurice now the reason
why it matters for maurice is because
once they're there and they're basically
in
in portugal and i wouldn't really call
it r r they're just kind of between
missions at the moment uh you end up
having merit now philip merritt of
course we know is one of the guys who
was there
and the the outset of them all kind of
being rounded up and then taken to
camp cathcart and then ultimately taken
to their final destination where they
were imbued with the super soldier serum
uh this guy is obviously racist right i
mean
it's one of the things that's kind of
given he refers to them as like boys
things like that and his racism would
become a lot more prevalent
the the you know further you get into
the story but one of the things that he
does is he reveals to maurice the fact
that his dad killed himself that his dad
killed
killed his mom and then killed himself
because when they were given the news
that maurice had been killed
uh essentially they couldn't you know he
couldn't really handle it right his dad
couldn't handle it and when maurice
learns that he immediately loses it now
what it does is it leads to maurice
actually killing one of the other
guys and then attacking merit and
breaking his collar bone and so when you
have this happening and maurice of
course
essentially perishes as well basically
isaiah is the only guy left
and so what it does is it basically
leads to isaiah being the sole survivor
and then having a meeting with christ
where he's just kind of like look like
it's the nature of this thing right like
understand
if you continue doing the missions as
you're supposed to then your family will
survive
and while it's not necessarily on the
nose the message that's being delivered
here is
do what we tell you to or we'll kill
your family and then we'll kill you
right like that kind of a thing we'll
wipe it all off the face of the map
because in reality it's in the best
interest of the military to essentially
tie up all loose ends but one of the
things that's also established here
by uh by reinstein is they're really not
even just weinstein but by uh walter
nagle kind of operating under the name
of jeffrey reinstein it was essentially
established that maurice had a
kind of exaggerated thyroid gland and
because of that it led to like an
increase in extreme emotional states and
that's one of the one of the the
problems that came with this iteration
of the super soldier serum is that again
steve rogers was kind of the perfect
the perfect serum was imbued with him
with regards to abraham erskine
everybody else like it all had some kind
of flaw to it and so if there was
already an existing exaggeration of the
thyroid gland and the super soldier
serum would enhance that at least the
way that it was made by
by weinstein it would exacerbate it and
make it worse right and so essentially
it was only a matter of time before
maurice had some kind of a psychotic
break
and then lost it the other part of this
is that you end up having isaiah being
sent
on a final mission but the problem is
that when that mission goes down one
it's radio silence
but two he ends up stealing the captain
america suit now the
again steve rogers was actually alive
and fighting in world war
ii at this point in time he somebody
just didn't know what was going on this
was essentially a backup suit right and
so because of the fact that isaiah was
so enamored by the idea of captain
america and fighting on the side of
righteousness and so on he steals what
was basically the old shield of captain
america or really i guess kind of the
newer version of captain america shield
combined with a backup captain america
suit and essentially becomes
the black captain america and goes
racing into what i believe is called
short speed
the uh it was a german camp uh it's
specific to this story as far as i'm
aware it didn't really exist
but goes racing in there and that's his
mission now when he gets here this is
when we really kind of start to get an
explanation he takes out a few of the
german guards and those guys are done
pretty quickly
grab some exp explosives and then goes
to destroy these different warehouses
they have but his actual mission is to
essentially track down
all the research of coke and so again
we'll get a lot more information with
regards to this guy once we get towards
the end of the story but when he gets
into the laboratory he ends up realizing
that coke has been experimenting on
people now
coke's not the only person to do that
something to understand and we'll talk
more about this is again as we get
towards the end is what was going on
with regards to
uh mr sinister right nathaniel essex
who's also a part of this as well
not this particular thing but a part of
it as well but when when isaiah gets in
there he finds just all these grotesque
experiments some of which involve young
people like kids
babies different things like that the
just the depravity of it all
is so extreme and so the results of that
is he he really is kind of breaking down
and struggling the whole time
and then a whole bunch of germans you
know where a whole bunch of people are
basically being put inside of a of a
building and then he runs inside as well
slams the door shut only to find out
it's a gas chamber right and like zyklon
b is getting ready to get pumped into
this thing
and that's gonna be it right and that's
exactly what happens that once he's in
there the super soldier serum allows him
to survive the experience but he's
literally
inside this room while all these jews
are dying and so it's a it's a little
crazy because once he starts to wake up
he's basically captured by the germans
now while that's all going on
there's a kind of explanation that's
being offered by way of
of essentially you know somebody in the
background talking to somebody else
right kind of explaining
what's going on to a degree right that
isaiah kind of realized that you can't
save everybody
things along those lines kind of
speculating to a degree on what isaiah
was thinking what he was going through
how this whole thing unfolded and so
ultimately we find out that it's his
wife faith
who's talking to steve rogers basically
telling captain america
all this stuff and so when he's kind of
like so isaiah's dead like isaiah died
at the camp her response is no whatever
would make you think that isaiah bradley
was dead and so from there you actually
kind of jump back a little bit right you
are really kind of jump back before
steve rogers had this meeting but after
the whole events with the camp and all
that kind of stuff so we're gonna have a
little back and forth here for the next
little bit
but you end up having steve rogers who
basically meets with philip merritt
who's in lompoc federal prison out in
california and this takes place about
five days before the meeting that he had
with faith
and philip is a guy who's essentially
been busted on seemingly
everything right killing a federal agent
commit a conspiracy to commit acts of
domestic terrorism
gun running money laundering
racketeering i mean if he did it
he's basically been thrown in jail for
it now there is a little bit of
of indication here that some of these
charges are trumped up or fake charges
just to kind of get him removed out of
the equation
the reality is doesn't make a whole lot
of sense right i mean if the
government's good at anything it's
killing people without anybody knowing
so i have a hard time believing that if
the government wanted this guy dead they
wouldn't just kill him right so it kind
of seems to be to move him out of the
way or he's actually guilty of all this
stuff
but one of the things that he talks
about is racism really kind of comes to
comes to sharp relief when we end up
finding out that somewhere along the
line reinstein was executed right that
uh
that walter nagel was basically killed
and that when that happened it was at a
meeting that he had where he had met
philip merritt and while philip merritt
was kind of a young person in the
military
and steve rogers was kind of there with
everybody else so philip was just kind
of a guy who was there that wasn't
really of any significant notice
that when uh when when walter nagle was
killed that you ended up having somebody
who basically
raced off to his laboratory and torched
it and that's when he realizes philip
merritt was the guy who did it then he
basically betrayed the country right
that he was essentially working
alongside the germans or at least that
seemed to be the case and that's when
his racism
full-on comes out that in the warehouse
that he had there was a lot of german
propaganda and then there was also the
uh the suit of captain america that
isaiah bradley had been wearing and so
that's kind of
the bunker situation is because the more
the conversation goes down the more the
philip merritt starts talking about
things
how like black americans were trying to
achieve equal rights and that you know
black americans need to be used for
cannon fodder effectively and that the
germans had it right when they were
basically rounding up people who were
deemed to be
undesirable and then gassing them
turning them into some kind of a forced
labor working them to death whatever the
case was
but like there was no reason to believe
that black americans could in any form
or fashion be useful in
uh in society as a whole without just
being kind of thrown out there as cannon
fodder right you know and
even goes as far as to refer to isaiah
bradley as captain americoon right so
like the racism here coming from this
guy
is pretty extreme now something to
understand because i'm sure a lot of
people who are kind of looking for a
reason to be mad
will like take this and run with it and
say like see marvel's racist that's not
really true right the important thing to
understand when it comes to period
pieces like this
it's designed to reflect one how far how
much things have changed in different
ways
and two the backwards mindsets of
various people and and then
you know to kind of illustrate that
point you do end up seeing instances
where like a racial term gets thrown in
but it's not being racist for the sake
of being racist right it's designed to
illustrate a point and so what you end
up doing is switching over to isaiah
bradley after he had essentially
you know escaped or at least you know
woken up inside of one of the gas
chambers and he's essentially been
snatched up and brought towards the
journey brought to the german fury and
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because what he ends up really doing is
trying to like put forward this idea
that isaiah bradley should work for them
and he actually ends up bringing in like
the german minister of propaganda now
one thing to understand about what
germany did back in the day during world
war ii
is propaganda was a huge part of the
german of the the german war effort and
in fact during events like like when
germans were when germany was taking
stalingrad right they would go through
and routinely blare right they would
just play these these
kind of broadcasts where they would tell
like the russian soldiers the soviet
soldiers like
surrender to us and we'll treat you
better than your than your leaders do
because at that point in time
uh if you were part of the red army they
would actually kill you for retreating
right which is one of the reasons why
so many russian soldiers died because
like if you they would they would just
like
send you forward and you would fight and
if you threw down your arms and you just
ran backwards you'd get killed by your
own officers right by your own your own
commanders
it was pretty backwards and it was
pretty extreme but as far as
as stalin was concerned it was the only
way to force people to fight and so
because of that
you kind of have isaiah who doesn't
really take it seriously right that the
you know that girls and those guys are
kind of like hey look like you know
understand like your people are being
treated terribly in the united states
right like your people come out of
slavery right you've never really had
equal rights in comparison to white
americans you experience racism at
seemingly every turn we here in germany
we're a lot more enlightened
than america is we're far more
enlightened we're trying to do the right
thing we're trying to make the world a
better
place so come side with us and we'll
take care of your people right we'll
take care of black americans uh and it's
it's
it's a tough sell if you know anything
about germany
and that's why isaiah is just kind of
like no that's not gonna happen like my
wife would kill me if i sided with the
germans so obviously he's not even
remotely taking these guys seriously
and so following that you know basically
the german fear is just like throw him
in a vehicle
you know and then we'll just we'll we'll
have him eliminated but then the
question kind of becomes like if this
guy is capable of what he's done so far
then like like the americans have been
have gotten pretty far
with coke's formula right so again kind
of an important thing going on here and
something to keep in the back of your
head now ultimately of course
isaiah is told by by the german fear hey
look uh we're gonna get you cleaned up
we're gonna treat your wounds and then
we're gonna let you go isaiah is no fool
right he's like
these guys are gonna kill me but there's
not much he can do right there's not a
whole lot that he can do there
instead what ends up happening is that
you kind of switch back to philip
merritt and the meeting that captain
america had with him
along with uh along with the the fbi
agent of course who's you know
half-black or at least uh has german air
in his blood and ultimately like when
they go to leave
philip asks uh captain america to
basically give him an autograph
now captain america does but there's a
priceless to be paid for it and so while
they're leaving you end up having this
guy who starts talking to steve rogers
and saying you know there's a story that
my grandfather
you know grandfather klaus always told
he always told this story and it was
interesting the way this works is that
after isaiah bradley is basically taken
by the germans for the intention of
being
executed that the the convoy is
essentially knocked over right like the
road to auschwitz is
which is where he's supposed to be going
is essentially intercepted by a handful
of black soldiers and one of these guys
is the grandfather of this fbi agent and
the way this works the way it's kind of
explained to us
is that isaiah bradley had essentially
been taken by these guys and then
essentially brought into a series of
onto a series of supply lines
and more or less brought back to the
united states right these are black
soldiers right these are these are our
black allied soldiers
and so it's a it's a cool thing to see
that he was he's a black captain america
saved by black americans who were
fighting during world war ii and so what
you end up doing is kind of jumping back
in
at least as far as two days ago where
you have captain america meeting with uh
with walker price now walker price is
the guy who was running that right that
military officer the guy who was a dick
uh he was the one that was running
everything
this is captain america basically
confronting him and he essentially says
like you know i want to know what's
going on here
right like i want to know everything
that's happening and and he really kind
of asked him about like
about like isaiah bradley but he says i
need to explain you know how you could
wind up running
coke international and and what you have
to do with isaiah bradley and all that
stuff and walker's response is it's all
the same story and so this is where you
kind of get this huge exposition on
what's going on
and you actually you actually learn some
really intriguing things here so one of
the first things that's established here
is that the notion of germany using what
was in effect
uh ethnic cleansing models was based on
the united states and that's true
so to sidetrack from the story for a
second kind of dealt here in the real
world there was a guy by the name of
harry laughlin and he
basically lived or was head of the
eugenics record office from 1910 to
1939. but important thing to understand
here is that you had in the united
states what was called the immigration
act of 1924
back during that point in time and in
the years leading up to it the united
states practiced eugenics
the way it worked is the u.s would
basically determine what individuals
were considered the most desirable those
individuals who were
chinese and japanese were considered the
least desirable and those individuals
from like
from from eastern europe were considered
a little more desirable than chinese or
japanese but still
undesirable overall and so what the
united states basically did is it
created this kind of
hierarchy right those individuals who
were considered the least desirable
to the to the most desirable and that
those who were kind of classified below
with
a certain threshold the us would
involuntarily sterilize them when they
came into the us they would make sure
that they couldn't have any kids because
the united states wanted to keep america
ethnically cleansed they wanted to keep
it ethnically pure and it wasn't just
the us he was also britain who did the
same thing
and germany to a degree before the
before the fear and before the the
germans rose to power
before like you know everything popped
off with regards to the war
and so because of that uh the idea of
what was going on
during world war ii in the concentration
camps was rooted in what took place in
the united states that you know as far
as
as the more modern era the us kind of
spearheaded that stuff and that's one of
the things that he talks about here
right that like francis galton was the
one who came up with the idea of
eugenics in the first place the science
of improving the stock and it was
basically just a movement in the united
states
to sterilize individuals who were deemed
to be uh undesirable and ensure
they couldn't procreate in the united
states and taint the gene pool that was
the whole belief of america
at that point in time it was not
believed entirely in america that's
something that i want to clarify it was
not a wholly supported movement by
everybody in the united states but those
in position of power believed it was a
good idea
one of the things that came out of this
is the super soldier project now this is
where i want to kind of wrap everything
back together
and give you guys a more clear picture
here so when you look at something like
weapons plus you look at the super
soldier project all that kind of stuff
it really all starts with nathaniel
essex mr sinister right he was a guy who
believed
that mutants were slowly rising to
prominence and individuals were
developing powers and he was curious
about how all that dna worked and so
during world war ii he operated inside
of a concentration camp performing all
kinds of heinous experiments on people
uh that he believed possessed what was a
mutant gene or trying to understand the
human genome
better so he could predict who was going
to become a mutant and who wouldn't now
ultimately when the the forces of his
concentration camp were liberated by the
invaders right so captain america bucky
barnes
name with a submariner the original
human torch jim hammond that he
essentially went underground but his
research had been discovered by a guy
named truett hudson who ended up
changing his name but truitt hudson had
used all this stuff and then
created what was in effect quote unquote
the the weapons plus
project as we more or less know it today
but the precursor to the weapons plus
project and the precursor to project
wide awake came by way of like isaiah
bradley and eugenics experimenting and
understanding the human genome to
eliminate undesirable people but the
antithesis to that
is if we can eliminate undesirable
people by essentially sterilizing them
is it possible to manipulate the human
genome to create desirable people
and the germans were the ones who came
up with that kind of secondary thought
process
and that's why you saw the united states
government sending in nick fury and the
howling commandos to snatch up abraham
erskine and whisk him to the united
states for his super soldier serum
which could be used to create the
perfect super soldier now once that
project was kind of off to the races and
you had truett hudson and all them
that's when it goes into the united
states creating and using it as a model
to kind of contain and control the
mutant threat that's where the precursor
element
of project wide awake comes into play
right because it's one thing to say okay
like let's create super soldiers or
create the perfect person the perfect
being
and then like fill our society with that
but then when mutants start popping up
and there's people with extraordinary
powers
then the role of the government becomes
self-preservation and so then it's like
okay well then let's just find a way to
contain and control the mutant threat
which is why captain america was
originally supposed to be brought back
presumably my wife and then
reconditioned to go forward and be the
first of a new line of super soldiers
assuming that abraham erskine hadn't
died but again that's that's that's
how it was all kind of supposed to play
out that's kind of the big broad
perception of it
um we can do a far more nuanced
explanation kind of run through the
whole timeline
if you guys are interested i don't
remember whether we have a video on it
or not i don't believe we do
i don't think we have a video where we
kind of explain the timeline of the
weapons plus project
the the creation of captain america all
the other weapons plus or all the other
weapons projects that were created you
know how it involves and how it brings
in like blue marvel adam brashear how it
ties in i say
isaiah bradley how it all leads into
like wolverine and then eventually
deadpool and all that kind of stuff i
don't think we've done that right so
it might be hooves to kind of do this
this huge explanation video
kind of breaking down weapons plus but
the reality is that uh the actions of
price are really pretty heinous here
right and it's one of the things where
he says like hey yeah we did some pretty
shady things but that's just the nature
of war right it's just the way things go
uh so i mean i'm not going to apologize
for it but the important thing is that
originally you had coke and weinstein or
or uh walter nagel if you want to call
him that and they were in effect the
same thing right they were kind of
working on the same project but
ultimately they were sent to the united
states for the purpose of showcasing
the ability to move eugenics beyond
simply just forced sterilization of
undesirable people and actually create
individuals who were of a higher
a higher stock quote unquote but when
the war broke out you had coke who went
back to germany and you had reinstate
who stayed here
and so the the race was basically on you
had germany trying to create their own
super soldiers and then you had the
united states trying to create theirs
and all of it came in the aftermath of
abraham erskine dying everybody was
trying to create new captain america
type
guys new super soldiers and reinstead
and coke were just a couple of examples
of that there were a lot of others who
were doing it too again truett hudson
who went eventually changed his name to
abraham cornelius uh
you had all kinds of stuff that was
going on right you had all these things
that were that were playing out but with
regards to this great big huge
revelation and the fact that that steve
rogers is kind of being confronted with
the the idea
that his origin is rooted in the idea of
removing
undesirable people from society that
what we also find out that he had done
is he
had essentially you know used a whole
bunch of the money that he got in terms
of back pay from his time in the
military
and bought up enough stock options in
coke international that he can appear at
a shareholder meeting and he's bringing
the entire military record of of
christ with him and is going to dump all
that information out there right and
basically tell the world
what price is about and so because of
the fact that he's kind of the the head
of the company
that would be huge right it'd be a huge
revelation because philip merritt was
the one
that handed all that information over
and so you end up having steve rogers
you know kind of picking up in the
current moment right now steve rogers
goes and visits with faith and when that
happens you basically have them kind of
talking
leading into the moment where she you
know essentially talks about everything
that was going on with regards to isaiah
and all that kind of stuff and so once
she takes off her headdress
you know we she basically says like i
will take you to meet isaiah bradley but
there's something that you need to
understand here
right the impact of the super soldier
serum as it was given to you was a
perfected version right you are the
perfect human being as far as isaiah
bradley goes he was given an
imperfect one and so one of the side
effects of what happened is that he was
ultimately sterilized right it kept him
from being able to have any kids now
luckily for us
we had a daughter before that took place
but one of the other side effects that
came from this is he's kind of been
reduced to a rudimentary
state he doesn't really speak anymore
and he's more child than adult and so
she's like that's something that you
need to be prepared for you need to be
aware of that and so steve rogers goes
to meet with isaiah bradley and the
crazy thing about this and that's that's
one of the cool concepts here isaiah
bradley is exceedingly well known in the
black community right within the black
community
everybody knows who isaiah bradley is
and he's met with everyone right he met
with nelson mandela he met with
met with malcolm x he met with all kinds
of people james brown all kinds of guys
right even even like bono from
too which i don't really know if i would
call that an achievement like bono's an
but the fact remains that
it's one of these things where within
the black community he's highly
celebrated right as the black captain
america and it's one of those concepts
and it's not really something that's
explored until you get into the crew but
one of the things behind isaiah bradley
is that he
is was almost considered to be a myth
right it's one of those things where
like it's a champion of the black
community that no one really knows about
that it's very very tight-knit very
closed off
and unless you're within the black
community or you know people in the
black community they're willing to tell
you about him you would never know he
even existed in the first place and so
it's kind of a crazy thing that goes on
because
steve rogers goes to visit him and and
is just kind of enamored by him right
there's a there's a lot of
sadness and guilt that goes into this
because of everything isaiah bradley had
been through
that any chance of having a full-on
meaningful life
was stripped by the federal government
from him being able to achieve those
things right to go on
and to see his family grow and prosper
them having more children right all the
the tormented things that he'd seen
the kind of things he put up with you
know the fact that he lost his ability
to function on a high on a high level
and it's kind of been reduced to a child
who's also been sterilized steve rogers
takes a lot of guilt with this you know
and while it's not necessarily steve
rogers fault directly the fact that he
didn't know that there was a black
counterpart to himself out there
is something that he struggles with and
so he really is here in a lot of ways to
make amends and to say you know as a
person who represents what are supposed
to be
the greatest ideals of america america
has failed you america has failed you in
the worst way
and so while i can't make up for that in
the most grand sense what i can do
is try to bring at least some merit of
satisfaction to your life and so what he
does is he actually gives him
the old captain america uniform that he
wore the one that he wore during world
war ii which brings a huge amount of
happiness to
to isaiah bradley right and the two of
them end up getting a bit of a picture
together that's taken by faith and
that's where the story ends
uh but isaiah bradley's story is amazing
that's why i told you guys
truth red white and black is amazing and
here's a funny thing you guys were the
ones who told me about it beforehand i
didn't initially know this existed but i
was like what in the world and then and
then you guys were like like i want to
say maybe a year or two ago you guys
were like you should cover truth red
white and black and it really is a great
story right it's an incredibly
great story so yeah isaiah bradley this
is his origin guys this
is this is the origin of this guy and
it's cool so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
you